Let's look at the solution to our unlock
quiz where we were asked really what does unlock
do. Does it just store zero to lockvar, does
it, check whether the lockvar is one and then
do a store conditional atomically to make it
zero? Or do we need additional atomic instructions, that
are going to somehow, unlock the lock? And the answer
is that. Unlike the lock function, where we needed
to both, check whether lock is available and, make
it busy, in one go, the unlock function, is done
only by the thread that actually has the lock.
So when we get to unlock we know that the
lock is busy, because we made it busy. All
we have to do is just, make the lock free.
We can do that by writing zero in any
way we want. So we chose the simplest way of
just doing a normal store to the lock
variable. So we don't need to atomically test
whether it's one and then, make it zero.
And we definitely don't need additional atomic instructions.